bread takes time and patience and things
sometimes go wrong but that's such a
beautiful product and such a beautiful
craft what i like about this world you
can create whatever is in your mind it's
just about the feeling you know it has
its own life it has its own way of
reacting it's like trying to get this
dough that's massive it always feels to
me like i'm taming a beast
[Music]
[Applause]
being french i guess we we have bread at
every meal
bread has always been around and we do
things here in a very traditional way
so when we mix my hand we're going to
start mixing the levant to the water and
break it down then we're going to
incorporate all the ingredients the
gluten gonna start to try to get access
to the water like string that come
together and attach to each other when
you pull the dough it's like you're
pulling back
i used to work in a bank i was getting
older and tired of working in a bank and
not having fun anymore i needed to do
something with my hands so dramatically
different from being a banker i feel
that being a baker is a great job and
craft to be able to work with your hand
and to feed the people of the community
i find it very theory operatic to to
shape and bread it's a great feeling
it's the best feeling ever because you
are in your world and you have the dough
it's a very
relaxed environment
[Music]
baking is mostly
waiting for the dough to be ready take
two to three days altogether but most of
the time nothing happens
a lot of time you just wait
time is probably the biggest ingredient
in the bread and that's why being a
small bakery matters because we have
time
all this time that you add in the
process adds a lot of dimension to a
loaf of bread
because of the yeast and the sourdough
is something that's moving and that does
what it wants based on how hot or cold
is the room how it's mixed that makes it
very challenging but very rewarding
the better you get your hands learn how
to play with the dough and how to shape
it and to make it do what you want it to
do you want the dough to be like a nice
pillow when it's fluffy and then you
play with it and you see how it turns
out
it can be more tricky so you need to be
careful when it works fine it's very
enjoyable when it doesn't it's not that
enjoyable bread takes time and patience
and things sometimes go wrong but that's
such a beautiful product and such a
beautiful craft
[Music]
it's the best feeling ever to be able to
produce something that you're proud of
i'm sure that's why everybody in the
kitchen goes to work every day
[Music]
when i was at school i remember that we
produce bread every day and it would
bring bread to people being your doctor
or being new friends and people get very
excited
through the centuries there's always
been something very important for the
culture if you look back in france you
would have people who would go to the
oven at the end of the village and they
would all bake usually once a week
their bread in a communal oven
and that's where the scoring is coming
from the scoring comes from i think he's
here for a reason because it allows the
bread to expand and to get to get nicer
and to get more volume because you
create some weakness in the crust but
back then the scoring was only a way for
the home baker to sign his loaf so that
when it comes out of the oven you can
see which one it is
people see just some bread as something
that's gonna keep in a bag for two weeks
that is super white that has no crust
and that has a little flavor when i sit
the other way when the crust is super
dark you get a lot of flavor to the
crust you want this like nice sugar that
caramelized on the outside of the bread
you want some sound you can hear it
cracking that makes up the crust is nice
it's very fluffy inside and you get all
this bubble from fermentation i like it
with cheese obviously i like it with
butter it's very enjoyable
i think we care a lot and that shows in
the product and you learn so much and it
makes you very humble i mean it's a very
good balanced meal if you are not
allergic to gluten
[Music]
it was a very tough experience like
physically and mentally to be able to
open the bakery here
so okay but like 3 30. we come here we
start at 4 a.m and for many reasons i
think it's my home because that's why i
work and that's where i have most of my
days
it's tough right it's hot the door does
whatever it wants to do some days it's
heavy we carry a lot of dough around
standing all the time like in any
kitchen there are recipes and the
formula but then it takes a lot of
practice and experience to be able to
consistently produce good bread if you
follow a recipe and for a good cake and
you've got good technical skills you
should be okay for bread if you don't
know what you're doing the bread gonna
hit you back
[Music]
it's a lot but it's very rewarding
because i think is there something
magical in the way that people react to
bread
we did a baby shower and the
baby got born and now he's two years old
and we're still in contact we see people
getting married we see people coming to
neighborhood and growing with us and
then leaving the neighborhood so it
becomes i mean this is my social life
because i'm my customers i think there
are very few jobs like that
[Music]
when i'm making vodka all i hear is jazz
you know in jazz there's a lot of
improvisation um but within that
improvisation there's a set form our
bobcat dough is a hybrid between a bread
and a pastry so it has eggs in it it has
some butter it's pretty rich it has
yeast in it so it's like a wild beast
you know it has its own life it has its
own way of kind of reacting you know
it's like trying to get this dough
that's massive you know and it's like
wild it always feels to me like i'm
taming a beast i grew up in israel and
in israel it's basically a standard you
have to have chocolate vodka all the
time it's a beautiful play on
traditional
eastern european dessert and what we did
is basically
created a whole new hybrid of it so we
laminate the pastry which means
engulfing butter within the dough giving
it a series of folds
and i love butter there's nothing in you
know i love butter i just you know i
adore it
i dream about layers like this is what i
do this is what i live for once i had a
dream that i was in between the layers
but i don't know
that might just be me i don't know
in my past i was doing things that were
not even related to food i was a soldier
and one day once i got out i said this
is not the life i want to live and i
discovered a a recipe just a very
standard recipe in an old cookbook it
was this old olive loaf honestly it came
out really bad when i made it but i
didn't know it for me it was the best
bread i ever made
and i remember becoming obsessed with it
it was just my life at that moment and i
knew it and it hit me you know
very very early that this is what i want
to do and i've been making vodka for
four years of my life every day almost
and every day has been different
julietta is a great teammate and i you
know we've been making vodka for a while
now making bobcats like a dance we know
each other without even having to talk
[Music]
[Music]
babka was was pretty much more of a
saturday thing for us we used to wake up
early and try to like slice a few vodka
pieces before my parents woke up you
know it's all about stealing food for me
i don't know what's going on but um we
make thousands of baptists throughout
the day vodka is great all day long even
if you buy it and you have it the next
day you'd still have a lot of joy out of
it but um when it's just the right
temperature just cooling down from the
oven it's still a little moist inside
you have the syrup that's still just
starting to to basically encase all that
moisture all of these are aromas and all
these flavors are enhanced at that
certain times and then we try not to eat
them
i usually fail
i really adore making vodka it is my
life
[Music]
but when i when i watch jeremy make
khalak you know he takes color making to
a whole new level
[Music]
my favorite braid to make is the rala
because what i like about my job is to
be creative
i actually decided to make bread when i
was 14 years old because i went to do a
two-day stage
in france and
i really like to make bread and a very
interesting about it
so then i went to school for that and
then since this age i never stopped
it's just about the feeling you know
when you have to feel the dough it has
to be soft otherwise you won't be able
to make your final shape when you poke
the dough it has to spring back a little
bit
every day i try to wake up at 2 30 a.m
get on the train get the apron on take
some bread and then let's start the day
when you love your job it's gonna make
it very like easier to run your day
because if you don't like you know what
you do it's not gonna be that easy every
day
i'm really proud to make definition what
i like about this board is you can
create whatever is in your mind
the radar should taste a little bit
sweet but it goes with everything i like
to eat
a lot with honey
it's like a sharing bread so this
reminds me when i was in my family i did
melee dinner and then we just take a
piece of bread pizza
you know i grew up um having khala on
our dinner table every friday the khala
was like this centerpiece thing and
me and my younger brother we always try
to like pick at the khala before dinner
starts every friday night we used to eat
the entire kalab and we were done after
that so we just ate the challah and then
we left they were very very angry very
angry
[Music]
i used to work in a bank i was a soldier
i was getting older and tired one day
once i got out i said this is not the
life i want to live i needed to do
something with my hands
[Music]
i decided to make bread and i was 14
years old brad has always been around
and he needs to tell a story so it's
like a wild beast you know it has its
own life that makes it very challenging
but very rewarding
i really adore making vodka it is my
life when you love your job you're gonna
make it easier to run your day it's the
best feeling ever to produce something
right off this is what i want to do
one baker can feed thousands of people
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is jeremy jam my name is ivan
lesnick my name is jessica
[Music]
and i'm big bright
[Music]
you